Transcriber:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Orit, yes.
And I study insurance.
Telling people that you study insurance
is not a good way to start a conversation.
In fact, if ever you need
to end the conversation,
try it, tell people you study insurance.
People don't want to talk about insurance.
They don't think it's all that exciting.
But I disagree.
I find insurance fascinating;
in fact, I find it magical.
And today, I'd like to show you why.
Now, the famous author Franz Kafka
used to work for an insurance
company in Prague.
And this is what Kafka
had to say about insurance.
He said, "Insurance is like a religion.
Insurance is like a primitive religion.
It's the religion of people
who believe that by having insurance,
they can ward off evil."
So according to Kafka,
what leads us to buy insurance
is not rational thinking,
but magical thinking.
It's the belief that if I have insurance,
somehow, magically, those negative events
that I fear in the future,
they're not going to happen.
Of course, this is totally irrational.
It's like believing
that if you have an umbrella,
it's not going to rain.
If your car gets stolen, yes,
the insurance company
will cushion the blow.
With the compensation money,
you could probably afford a new car.
But the fact that you have insurance
does not make your car
less likely to be stolen.
The risk is the same
whether you are insured or not.
So are people this naive?
Do they really believe
that if they have insurance,
they are less at risk?
Yes.
Perhaps not consciously, but they do.
Let me show you.
In one of my studies,
I asked people to predict
what is the likelihood
that in the future they will suffer
all kinds of medical misfortunes,
yhat they will need an operation,
physiotherapy or nursing care.
Another group was asked
to make the same predictions,
but we first asked them,
"Do you have health insurance?"
And of course they do.
Israel has universal coverage.
Reminding people
that they have health insurance
had a fascinating effect.
It made them feel less at risk.
Surprisingly, the effect
was not limited to medical problems.
It also made them believe
that they are less likely to lose money,
and my personal favorite,
asking people in Tel Aviv
if they have health insurance
made the prospect of a war
in Europe seem less likely.
(Laughter)
And that's magic.
Kafka was right.
There is an interesting paradox here.
We buy insurance against those events
that we fear the most.
But once we are armed
with this protection measure,
we feel that we are no longer
at risk somehow, magically.
And this protection effect
is not unique to insurance policies.
We see it with other
protection measures as well.
Let me show you.
In 2012, the citizens of Israel
were very worried about a possible
military attack by Iran.
And the government was distributing
gas masks to all the citizens.
At the time, we called people
and asked them to predict
what are the chances
that Iran would attack Israel
with weapons of mass destruction?
The ratings were quite high.
People were worried.
But if we first asked them,
"Do you have a gas mask?"
then the ratings dropped dramatically.
And that's magic.
Apart from the fact
that gas masks are largely useless
against weapons of mass destruction,
the fact that you have a gas mask
is unlikely to affect the strategic
or the tactical decision
of a foreign power.
We have to remember,
insurance is an antidote,
it's not a vaccine.
It doesn’t ward off evil;
it doesn't eliminate
the risks that we face.
However, when it comes to insurance,
the distinction between
an antidote and a vaccine
somehow gets blurred in our minds.
Why does it happen?
It happens because people
are not that good
at assessing risks rationally.
Let me give you an example.
When I arranged my flight to come here,
I had to decide if I wanted
to buy travel insurance.
Rationally, I should have based
this decision on several considerations:
the price of the policy, of course,
the value of my luggage,
the aggravation
that I'm likely to experience
if my luggage gets lost.
And of course, the likelihood
of such an event, right?
But most of the time, we're just too busy
to make such rational calculations.
And anyway,
I doubt that Lufthansa are very keen
to share their damage statistics with me.
So what do we do instead?
We rely on our intuition.
So how do we evaluate risks intuitively?
We start by imagining
the outcomes that we fear.
So here I am,
it's late at night,
I'm sitting at this airport,
all the other passengers
already collected their luggage and left.
I realize that my own suitcase
is now probably heading to the North Pole.
Thinking about this scenario
creates anxiety,
and then we use the level
of anxiety that we feel
in order to assess the probability.
So if I'm feeling terrified,
I will infer that the risk
of such an event is quite high.
But you see, this is
an intuitive risk estimate.
It is entirely psychological
and emotion-based,
which is why it is also highly susceptible
to the magic of insurance.
Insurance reduces our anxiety.
First, because the outcomes
that we imagine are suddenly less grim.
Yes, I'm sitting at the airport,
yes, it's late at night,
all the other passengers had left,
but there will be this guy there,
they would give me a voucher,
eventually, I will get
compensated, it's OK.
Also, because we are conditioned
to associate insurance with safety,
security, tranquility and peace of mind.
And if I'm feeling less anxious,
I would infer that the risk
is not that high.
So there you have it.
I have insurance, and the risk is gone.
But why do we associate insurance
with peace of mind?
Well, first, in many languages,
this is exactly what the word
"insurance" means.
It comes from the word "sure,"
which means lack of doubts,
no unknowns that would sneak up
and bite you in the future, right?
But also because traditionally,
this is how insurance was promoted.
Let me show you an example.
This is a lovely advertising toy
that was distributed to visitors
at the British exhibition in 1924.
So you see this guy
and he looks terrified.
He is barraged by the bricks of doom,
fire, accident, falling on his head.
And the tag on the bottom,
it reads "anxiety," which perfectly
describes the guy's expression.
But if you pull on that tag,
something slides inside,
and the guy transforms.
First, he now has the protection
of the Prudential insurance helmet,
and his expression
is changed into a smile.
You know why?
Because Prudential insurance
dispels anxiety.
Modern images of insurance
convey the same message.
Insurance logos often incorporate
supporting hand below,
and umbrellas above, ultimate protection.
And then travel insurance ads.
They could easily be mistaken
for vacation brochures, right?
Romantic couples,
exotic islands, palm trees.
And if for some reason
you need images of smiling,
happy people wearing white,
do an image Google search
with the words "pension plans"
or "health insurance."
Insurance ads rarely show you
sick people, smashed cars, torn suitcase.
The message is loud and clear:
You have insurance,
all is well in the world.
However, to get us to buy insurance,
the promoters must also work our fears.
Which is why, right after
you paid a lot of money
for a top of the line refrigerator,
the same seller who, just moments ago,
were explaining
how reliable this product is,
is now telling you that it may
break down at any moment,
which is why you should buy
the extended warranty.
And with some credit cards,
you could get free travel insurance.
All you need to do is to call the agent.
But when you make this call,
you are told, yeah, but the free deal
is only for the basic plan.
Basic plan doesn't sound
good already, right?
And then you get to hear a list of things
that you are not covered against,
like fires and heart transplant
and floods, etc.
But if you pay one more
dollar a day, right?
And your active imagination does the rest,
with each item on the list,
your anxiety is mounting,
and you don't ask yourself,
"Hey, I'm going to Paris,
why would I care about a tsunami?"
You pay the dollar, and all is well
in the world again.
In fact,
just realizing that we are not
covered against something
is enough to distort
our perception of risk.
I once asked people to imagine,
in one of my studies,
that they're going to go on a trip
and they plan to buy
travel insurance at the airport.
But by the time they reach the counter,
boarding had already started,
and they have to board that airplane
painfully aware that they are not covered.
And then I asked them to assess
all kinds of travel-related risks.
And these were dramatically inflated,
compared to the ratings of people
who did have insurance.
For example, lost luggage,
the risk of lost luggage,
almost 50 percent.
What are the chances
that you will need hospitalization?
Almost 45 percent, well, 45 percent.
And how about,
you will need to be rescued?
Thirty-one percent.
I remember the first time
I saw this data, I was speechless.
I was thinking,
"Guys, if this is what you believe,
why would you ever leave home"
you know?
(Laughter)
Yeah.
Boarding an airplane
with no insurance is tempting fate.
It's like realizing that your insurance
policy had just expired
and not renewing it?
Grave danger, indeed.
Your appliances, they know, you know.
So we buy insurance
and restore our peace of mind.
And now you're probably asking yourself,
"But peace of mind is good.
What's wrong with peace of mind," right?
"What's the problem?"
The problem is that we are highly
likely to be over-insured.
What does it mean?
Well, first,
we may be protecting ourselves
against really unlikely events
like a tsunami in Paris.
Or we may be paying a lot
to prevent a trivial loss.
Does it really make sense to extend
the warranty on an old washing machine?
And if you will examine
your own policies back at home,
many of you will find
that you have redundant coverage.
You are paying several policies
on the same event.
Many of you do that.
Me included, and I should know better.
So ...
This kind of behavior
can get people in debt,
and even if they don't,
this is money that we could spend
in far more pleasurable ways, right?
At least I can.
But selling peace of mind is a problem
for the insurance companies as well.
Why?
The insurance companies are well aware
of the problem called “moral hazard”.
You see, when people are insured,
they become negligent.
They start leaving
their valuables out in the open.
They don't check their fire alarms,
they drive faster.
In short, they act in ways
which put them at greater risk.
Now, the insurance companies,
they believe that we behave like that
because we know that if something happens,
someone else will pay.
Which is why many policies
include deductibles.
That's the money that comes
out of your pocket, right?
So the deductibles are there to make sure
that some of the risk
will stay with the client.
But based on the research
that I just shared with you,
it is entirely possible
that the reason that we are careless
is not just that we think
that someone else will pay,
but it's also the magical belief
that if I have insurance,
it's not going to rain.
The damage is not going to happen,
and magical thinking
is not susceptible to deductibles.
What are the lessons to be learned?
For us, for you?
Next time you consider buying insurance,
remember Kafka.
Ask yourself:
Am I buying insurance
for the right reasons?
Am I making a sound economic decision
or merely trying to please my psyche?
As for the insurance companies,
I hope they will consider
changing their message.
Don't sell magical happiness.
Encourage us to buy insurance
when it is economically rational
and the responsible thing to do.
And finally,
guys, I hope that next time
someone says "I study insurance,"
you would say, "Wonderful.
Please tell me more."
Thank you.
(Applause)